today we are celebrating the 20th season
of the voice i'm here with coaches blake
shout out to nick jonas
yeah um so it was recently announced
nick that ariana's now coming she's
going to take your seat next season so
here's the reason why i asked what
do you have wait a minute exactly wait
exactly
it's just this season so like here's my
question though do you have any advice
for her
uh no i mean ariana as we all know is
one of the best
singers in the game and she's gonna be
an incredible coach
uh i i think the only advice i would
give is just not to trust
any one of you
we've been feeding her lots of useful
advice yeah i'm sure
very useful yes yeah uh but she's gonna
kill it she'll be great
yeah um i thought yeah you could at
least warn her about the one she's
probably gonna sit next to
might be nice all of you she watches the
show though thoughtful she knows does
she knows about blake she does watch the
show
everybody about yeah everybody knows
lies and deception i just hope i don't
step on her
look at her she looks a tiny on there
she's [ __ ] tiny
the height differential between the two
of you will be substantial wow
i really hope she's sitting right next
to you it'll just look amazing
so wait are y'all scared of ariana yes i
am too i'm terrified
somebody literally asked us in the
interviews yesterday we were going
together and they said what do you think
about arianna i was like i think this is
my last chance to win
i was like ariana has a huge fan base
and they are fervent and if they show up
to vote we're all in trouble
100 are you scared at all
no what i'm not afraid
they pay me to win oh my gosh
ariana fans is that you guys
are how silent you are
okay well speaking of scared um i saw
you just had an incident with a possum
um what happened what'd you say i had an
instant you had an incident with a
pocket incident with a possum yeah
they should have sat you next to me so
you can hear me
uh i did i i was i was at the house
in oklahoma and i was just i was there
by myself
and i just grilled something on the
grill and i got it out i was letting it
cool off and i went back to get it and
it's a
damn possum over there look eating my i
actually grilled some fish oh my god i
was like hey man
i didn't actually see this whole thing i
didn't know what they hate
the food was it food oh
i later got i i got to i don't know if
y'all have the video i ended up petting
it and hanging out with it
were you grilling opossum there it is
there i am petting it
i wasn't grilling an apostle look at it
he likes me real quick question have you
ever heard of rabies
yeah oh well you're probably not going
to air the next video
well no no i'm just kidding oh what
okay so john have you ever encountered a
wild animal
well the scariest time we were in
tanzania ooh east africa
and a black mamba
oh which is a snake which i know which
is deadly
is deadly i did not see this black mamba
but
everyone who was with me saw it near me
and i had
didn't see it i was walking the other
way but i was close enough to it that it
could have
bitten me but i escaped it and then
everyone was like john did you just see
that black mamba
and i completely missed it but that's
probably why you didn't get bit though
because you didn't freak out
yeah well i didn't notice it that's what
i'm saying you were so calm and so it
was right there though it could have
gotten me
damn yeah that is wild because i've been
on one of those safaris i think they
just carry a gun in case they don't
carry like you know something to save
your life and get bit by themselves
like wow that's scary yes so i
i didn't know to be scared or not
because i didn't actually see it but
everyone around me was very scared for
me
oh my god i'd have freaked you have you
ever had anything crazy like animal i
have
yeah not as scary as that okay um
but i i got chased by a pack of coyotes
once
come on i swear to god a pack you jonas
boys every one of you tell crap like
that
wait what do you mean like a pack of
kite that's dangerous yeah so
i was just coming out of a movie theater
and uh
this is in los angeles this is in los
angeles and
i stepped outside and start walking by
myself walking home my friend's like
we'll give you a rise like i want to get
some
fresh air and so i'm walking and then i
see these eyes
in the dark and then i see about six
more sets of eyes
and they just went in an honor and they
take off running after me
that's terrifying so i go full sprint
like this about
half a mile uh to my house jump the
fence and they're all at the fence
and they don't chase people normally
they do in a pack though they will
so it was quite frightening i i i should
mention that when i was getting the
fresh air i may have
you know a little bit given as an aroma
yeah to be attractive
okay okay so wait so this may or may not
have happened
are you saying coyotes are attracted to
the smell
you had like a bunch of beverly hills
chihuahuas chasing like it's a wild
rabbit yeah no one else was with me i
can't be sure that is what happened
oh my god
you lost god you lost me at fresh air in
los angeles
and deception agreed so before we go to
break i want to talk about something
that happened
earlier this season the date was october
19
2020 i graciously invited blake to be on
my show to promote his vodka
not only did he forget his team kelly
jacket um this happened
because i've noticed over the years that
you play a lot of games even
outside of this show i do like you're
you're a gamer
i'm a winner as well a winner
exactly right which maybe maybe this
this gift will
goes against that idea that you're a
winner oh so it's a lie
this is a gift that represents
every person who has beaten you on your
show
with the podium that i gave you
wait a minute all these people have beat
me
i i never miss an episode of your show
and i wrote down every single time
somebody has beaten you
i hate that wall um there are now
whatever
17 photos up there including blanks yep
i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever